[Applaudissements]
les photos de wagonnets de son pote à
très très rare de bois de suite si je
suis content je crois ne me touche pas
mais la différence entre les épinards et
la sodomie
non seebach où il n'ya pas de différence
je peux rajouter tout le beurre que tu
veux les enfants n'aiment pas ça cherry
prends-moi prends moi j'ai envie de toi
pour moi je dis ça va pas tu es folle on
est dans l'avion il ya plein de gens
mais nan c'est la nuit tout le monde
dort prends-moi prends moi maintenant je
te dis c'est impossible
les gens dorment tu veux je te le prouve
isla l'écrit est ce que quelqu'un aurait
un stylo personne ne bronche toi prends
moi l'autre il prend l ed black toute la
vie au petit matin une hôtesse de l'air
qui paie sa tournée à une petite vieille
qui grelottent de froid fait madame vous
avez froid a dit oui j'ai froid mais
pourquoi vous n'avez pas demandé une
couverture une couverture ya un mec il a
demandé un crayon ici par balle aux
politiques vieilles traverses la forêt
la nuit ouais et tient une enfant de non
non non non non elle fille était dit
j'ai peur j'ai peur et le privé fait moi
tout à l'heure au retour quand je serai
tout seul tu crois que j'aurais peur
gels elle est mignonne c'est pour me
rattraper un peu des autres est bien de
copains à discuter il y en a un qui dit
hier il m'est arrivé un truc incroyable
je faisais mon footing le long la voie
ferrée comme tous les jours et là je
vois attaché sur la voie ferrée une
fille sublime un canon une beauté
qu'est-ce que je fais là des tâches et
là je suis un rouge l'a ramené à la
maison je les [ __ ] toute la nuit dans
tous les sens dans toutes les positions
sont peu du 10 mai est à sucer voter non
c'est qu'on n'y avait pas la tête
[Rires]